uh we also saw something the other day
that i really liked i cried
and it's my beautiful octopus lover
what's it called
oh then my octopus teacher teacher
my god you see it no my lord i don't
know if it will hit
people a certain way or maybe the way
the way it hit me was
like a dump truck it hit me in ways i
don't i didn't think was
and she was such a [ __ ] [ __ ] about
it she's like you know you're just not
you're not the type to cry over stuff
like this you don't have
i didn't think so and i'm like what i'm
a feeler baby
right and i saw it and it was very
emotional
and i and i vowed today publicly
that i will never eat calamari or
octopus again interesting
never again what about cuttlefish yes no
cuttlefish
this is the [ __ ] out of cuddle fish it's
just the same babe cuttlefish
are just as intelligent and sentient no
they're not
[ __ ] does it have a netflix special yeah
they don't have what are your favorite
animals of all time
to eat no can we talk about that thing
and i'll get into that
okay i don't know what it's about yeah
i'll tell you what it's about some south
african man
right he has a midlife crisis okay and i
guess he's um
involved in um he's a either a director
or a videographer he produces like he's
a documentarian or whatever
and he does animals is that how you call
it with say it george yeah he's a
documentarian
and he he has a midlife crisis it's the
work is too overwhelming so he decides
just to [ __ ] it all and take a break
so he moves back to the beach house that
he grew up in
with his family right something like
that something like close to it it's in
south africa it's right on
and he decides to um swim every day
right in um his little car the tip of
south africa and this is the cove
and he starts documenting things with
his cameras
and he doesn't do it with a scuba deer
gear he free dives
oh wow yeah and one day he um
spots a um an octopus
and he goes back and
obviously at first the octopus like what
the [ __ ] i've never seen a white dude in
my life that what's he doing here you
know
so he builds this he builds yeah he
builds an obsession for this 200 meter
plot of underwater real estate basically
and so he builds an obsession and he
goes to this this
same little cove every day for like 350
days
and then what happens is this octopus
obviously is frightened by this you know
i mean initially
initially and then they develop a
friendship
what yeah it's really sad to the point
where
the octopus will you know throw out her
tentacle arm
and wrap it around his finger to say
hello or the octopus
she follows him she follows him the
octopus will come and
land on his chest and greet him hello
you know
it's so sad you know and um
there's so much drama i don't want to
get it will give it away no spoiler oh
wow it's
very dramatic but it's so well shocked
it's so well it's beautiful
if you're just a lover of nature like
even before the octopus story was
introduced
the moment he described like um
being underwater like flying i was
already crying
yeah it's it's one of those um movies
where
you i think i i there are some people
you know that aren't animal people
like for me you know when i look at my
dogs or my cats in the eyes
right there's a definite connection i
have
i know there's a comedy podcast but i
want to get real for a second
you know and i literally love them right
more than i love most humans like i
there's like a spiritual connection that
i have you know when i see
any of my dog's eyes and we connect in
that way
it fills me with such warmth and and joy
and it gives me um a reason to live
actually you know and it's like
i can understand how a man you know i
mean will go underwater
and bond and connect with another
creature
in that way especially in an intelligent
they say that an octopus is as smart as
a dog
as a primate as a primate yeah right so
um
you know when you see like plankton
[ __ ] them you know what i mean i'll eat
the [ __ ] i like a blue whale eat
thousands of them right but
you know when it gets to a certain
intellect a point of intellect
you know in an animal like a dolphin
something like that right and you can
connect and they recognize and all that
stuff i just think that you can't kill
them
that's tricky though because intellect
is still
defined by what we think intellect is
but you know something that's sentient
and something so many things that aren't
even
animals have like a true intelligence to
them just like
like mushrooms and stuff well then we'll
stop eating mushrooms i mean what the
[ __ ] are you saying
you know what i can [ __ ] up a mushroom i
love some mushrooms man
i'm just saying like you know they're
everything it has it's really like true
everything is so important all living
things yes yeah yes
i i got to eat sometime you know i got
to eat something right he's hungry is
soy something that's
living all you eat is tofu i'm sure
there are people who would argue
yeah so like if they you can make an
argument with that you can make an
argument with
anything that we eat yeah like sriracha
like sriracha
yeah you mean is sriracha alive at one
point maybe
you know or tabasco you know
yeah yeah pepper it's a pepper right
yeah peppers were alive from a plant
right
you can't eat it you can't you can eat
it you know so it's like
you know you got to draw the line
somewhere sweetie right and i draw the
lines at [ __ ] octopuses
that's why when you see stuff like you
know the yulin doggie
eating festival it's an outrage you know
just because um
and i never thought that i know it's so
weird because i used to hate dogs and
cats
and all animals you didn't hate them you
just didn't know i hated them
i honestly what way did you hate me i
have like when myself okay
well don't don't talk about i don't know
things you you know
what do you mean i thought you would
talk about hurting one no no never hurt
one
but like that's hating to me my friend
before